what's up gq i'm will smith and today
i'm going undercover on the internet
that's never good
it's actually me
[Music]
twitter
is that it's a french company tritera
how have the rock and will smith not
made a buddy movie yet that's
that's my question
that's my question he's avoiding me i
might have to do an old school
smackdown walk up on him i don't know i
would love to work with the rock he he's
a beast post it i wonder how will smith
is really doing
i'm good
how the hell did will smith not win an
oscar for the pursuit of happiness
ding ding ding ding ding ding
death
row ads
yes
good question let's send that one to the
proper authorities replied
[Music]
why are will smith movies looking more
like a reality when we make movies like
that we go and find the people who are
at the forefront of technology and they
show us stuff that's 10 20 years away if
you look at enemy of the state it's
really scary to see how much it was
predicting the big brother condition we
are living today replied
how come no one talks about this
absolutely oh
man now wouldn't be caught in a crop top
anytime i try to say something about
something jaden wears
he sends me this picture i apologize to
everybody in philly and to the sixers
the sixers deserve a full shirt post it
why is will smith's dead shot not in the
suicide squad yet i was working and they
were ready to shoot it was a timing
issue they didn't cast anybody in
deadshot they didn't cast they left
deadshot out right
so idris is playing a different
character he's not playing or is he
playing deadshot
a different character all right cool so
i can come back
instagram
[Music]
what's instagram
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey will what is something you see in
jaden where you both are exactly alike
what is something you see in him where
he's completely different from you we're
both orchestrators we're like the person
that comes up with the idea of what we
want to do and start putting people
together and where we're not alike is
jaden doesn't give one
damn
what people think jaden is fearless in
his pursuit of his individuality i was
certainly not like that not so much as
i'm older but at his age i was easily
injured by people's opinions posted
real question is can you bring back the
family matching premiere outfits
we're gonna bring that back for king
richard a movie i got coming out i'm
gonna make everybody wear those tight
shorts to the premiere whole family
tight tennis shorts
was it your original idea to flip the
jacket inside out for fresh prints yeah
that was just mad creativity i just
wanted to do things differently than
they had done it before it's weird that
you do something that seems so little
and 30 years later is still around
quora
you ever heard of never heard of quora
what is will smith like in real life
he's like this
how was will smith discovered
man jeff made records in
his mom's basement there was a guy in
philly who was the brother of lawrence
goodman who was at pop art records pop
art records was a small label at the
time that had the whole juice crew that
was bismarcki
mcshantain shan rest in peace biz his
brother lived in my neighborhood dana
goodman discovered will smith moving on
what is good advice from will smith
drink
more water
in your opinion what is the worst and
best movie of will smith for the best i
think is a tie
between the first men in black and
pursuit of happiness for different
reasons those are the two almost perfect
movies worst i don't know white wild
west just is a thorn in my sight
i see myself with chaps i don't like it
i love that movie but we can get into
that all right
replied
what's the best song
by will smith i think summertime is the
best song i've ever made unless you
count the theme song to the fresh prince
nyx
webecopadaya with keppathaya
smith says he was admitted to a
pre-engineering
summer
program at mit for high school students
but he did not attend
well i did i never went to college at
all i got accepted in three different
places but it was after my record had
come out my mother was working really
hard to get me to college but i had no
intention of ever attending any college
anywhere
rap music post it
read it
would you rather spend the night hanging
out with nicholas cage but the night
must end with the two of you stealing
the declaration of independence or would
you rather spend the night hanging out
with will smith and tommy lee jones but
you get neuralized at the end of the
night damn the neuralization throws it
up memory is everything the narrative of
the experience is everything so to get
neuralized would be terrible
i am legend which ending do you prefer
i always prefer endings where my
character lives
serious
would men in black and the matrix be
better or worse if you swap the leads
keanu as j will smith as neo what if you
swap the mentor roles tommy lee jones as
morpheus lawrence fishburne as k
that's real that's very very interesting
i think would be very different movie i
think they would all
be good i think i'm gonna try this i
always thought a studio should take one
screenplay and give it to two sets of
actors and directors and crews and let
two different visions of the exact same
screenplay come out on the same day so
people have to go and see the two
totally different takes replied
what i want to know was there a specific
moment or something that happened that
really made him speak out more about
helping people grow it seems like he's
all about it now so there's a book
called the hero with a thousand faces by
joseph campbell and it's basically a
template of storytelling that has
existed from the beginning of human
history a hero goes off and fights and
fights you slay the dragon and you
uh gain the knowledge and then you come
back home and you teach people how to do
it so this phase of my life is giving
away and sharing and opening my life up
for examination and if somebody can get
something that helps them i'm a firm
believer that that's kind of the only
way to truly exist happily on this earth
for me at least
willow smith suggestions i've heard wait
a minute nine this is the one and wet my
hair and i think they were all really
beautiful pieces ethereal does anybody
have any willow smith suggestions for a
relatively new listener you can start
with lipstick lipstick's a really short
song uh what's the hook on the single
chest
uh transparent
transparent soul i can't hit the high
note transparent soul and lipstick are
the two ones you should try and clearly
i shouldn't try because that's her
father i just did a horrible job of
selling her music
youtube
[Music]
fresh prince uh this is epic which
episode is most memorable to you
and why
i think the one that people walk up to
me on the street about is the father
episode the one when will's father left
him that was a very special one for me
james avery and i had a really unique
father and son relationship on and off
camera that's most memorable for me
replied
anybody else miss it when will smith did
a song for every movie he did yes will
smith misses that there is nothing
like the combination of a hit movie and
a hit song when whitney houston has the
bodyguard and i will always love you i
had a tiger with rocky you know i
thoroughly missed that
tick-tock
[Music]
when did will get a tick-tock
i'm late af
that's as [ __ ] for people who don't
do it
i'm just putting it for people who don't
know
[Music]
uh did will smith just master gen z
comedy that's very funny i didn't come
on social media for a long time i was
kind of just watching and kind of
studying and getting a sense of what the
thing was you know my thing always is
find a master i got my dude jazz right
here so jazz follows me around how old
are you jaz 27 so you were like 23 ish
when you when you started stay with the
20 year olds they keep you looking hot
post it
[Music]
oh tragedy
will hun from tiana what is this okay
so jazz wasn't there for this
it was for st patrick's day so i was
there by myself and i had the camera
this was one where i should have run it
by somebody
i guess i'm just sorry i'm sorry
i'm will smith
and i'm signing off the internet
you